oops I and welcome to this video this is
a five minute it's game against raavan
and Indian flag it is right not that I'm
staking this ok i'm playing kind of the
what deck reversed the chrome free but
he goes for deform yeah this is an
interesting line and i just wanted to
try that out i hope it works out all
right not a huge fan of this particular
way of playing this with d4 I mean I'd
rather have engorge III but I'm not not
an expert i'm just trying trying this
out um d6 with this i'm not sure i'd
like to go see 65 somehow k prevents
that interesting
hmm yeah I wonder is it an idea maybe to
put the bishop like d 6 25 or something
like that an interesting interesting
idea yeah maybe interesting as in
nonsense I don't know
tricky yeah I don't really know this
position well so let's see him and yeah
I was thinking try to keep that or let
it let it being traded on another square
like him to take on b6 really it does
okay this that queenside structure is
very sturdy the bishop on c3 is quite
good of course but I have Knight to e5
as a possible idea and that's not so bad
I also want to go Queenie 74 h6 h3 was a
somewhat um curious decision ok so I
wanted to go here anyway now the night
his night can go h3 f 4 would be nice
actually to get to h6 and g5 and once
probably difficult to do
and I g4s of course as possible I don't
know it's not bad hey we'll play 9 h 3 I
guess what else but mr. fight what else
is there he has to go night age three so
there's something wrong with that that
I'm not seeing yeah you always ask
yourself they take a long time for for
something that looks completely forced
really one that did do did you
overlooked something so okay um I don't
really see a great idea here I don't
don't have any I don't sacrifice here or
something don't really and see a clear
way forward maybe hear something like 93
and queen takes you three can be can
become an idea but well have a look at
g7
covering 93 really wow okay I guess he
is worried I don't know what is that
idea here context is interesting but you
can cancel long then maybe let's do the
eggs do this or does he have aged 6 now
aged 69 h6 group h5 that could be a
problem that might be a problem oh yeah
it is possible
look h5 Quincy for age 60 x check check
it's a ton of checks am I losing I don't
know if I am okay what can I do
currently I don't see how I'm losing
after Luke h6 and maybe here no DJ he
does take it how am I losing here I
don't see it always he just playing at
our King Ditu and I should switch off
the mo by him I Kingda to and bringing
new chat ringing reinforcements no check
he goes I'm just a straightforward thing
okay hmm
o gauge seven maybe if i get that in its
got one porn right i mean he definitely
has compensation but is it more look
aged seven ok that is stupid yeah I
don't have a godsend because of that
made him hmm is it stupid
and he threatening queen AJ that's the
worst part that's the worst part
actually ah hell I know how annoying
that was that was not necessary of
course he had compensation but it wasn't
really that brilliant I don't think so
how would you do this here I it's the
opposite colored bishops Jack many many
situations where we will be a will offer
chances to draw I didn't want to give
him the passer so this is why I didn't
take
if I take on c4 you don't care and I try
something else going for activity we
should take C 4 and C go here Quincy
eight
yeah man played there very nicely check
check check check check
check I could have taken that bloody
rook check I didn't I take the rook oh
no why didn't I take the rook that's
stupid really stupid black resins you
just you just blundered that I believe
Oh what's their win check here with this
I can take this I just saw that too late
I don't know maybe I'm still lost but
engine is not convinced okay what I want
this this is this is going to be made so
I have to do this yeah this is the
engines line check check and whatever
that is said hey it's still the game
yeah I think Chang here this was
actually a good defense here with before
and stuff f4 is actually good for black
but this wasn't so stupid i thought it
was an interesting way to do it King
here Bishop there every Queen g2 was
better here I have to go to back to
evade I saw that too late yeah I was
interesting I mean he has compensation
but she doesn't have really an advantage
in this position at is some yeah
confirmed by the engine gives 000 I
overlooked nachi 6 of course Queen g8
hospital I want I want to go here k and
this is given by the comp
wiki line and that is assessed as equal
yeah I can easily believe that I mean
the porn is he has really worthless and
quite often the opposite colored bishops
give ya give room for getting an
initiative okay I also could have taken
probably yeah I should've just done that
I'm gonna win the porn hello that would
have been very easy anyway okay first
game of a session is always tricky
thanks for watching